atrincherados en medio de la selva
colombiana disidentes de la guerrilla de
las FARC parecen creer en la nueva
propuesta de paz total del presidente
izquierdista Gustavo Petro tenemos un
gobierno
progresista que nos inspira confianza
creemos de que de que de pronto
con él podemos llegar a hacer acuerdos
que favorezcan al pueblo colombiano
estos guerrilleros decidieron no firmar
con el gobierno de ese entonces el
acuerdo de paz de 2016 cuando se
desmovilizaron gran parte de las fuerzas
armadas revolucionarias de Colombia
otros regresaron a las armas a pesar de
suscribir El pacto al llegar Petro el
poder se abrió una nueva puerta para que
finalmente haya un alto al fuego en el
pueblo del Charco de nariño un lugar
históricamente olvidado por el estado
hay esperanzas de que resulte el nuevo
acuerdo como esperanzado con el proyecto
de paz total porque nos va a garantizar
de que la institucionalidad pueda llegar
aquí a nuestro territorio según el
Instituto para el desarrollo y la paz y
de paz el 65% de la población urbana y
rural del Charco ha sido objeto de
desplazamiento forzado
está esperando oportunidades de una vida
en paz no de que se de que se estabilice
una situación de no violencia que se
organicen bien las actividades de
educación de Justicia
desde una vida de presencia del Estado
social de derecho con oportunidades de
ingreso para la gente si bien las
negociaciones han empezado con la
guerrilla del eln el proyecto de paz
total También incluye a los grupos
armados como el clan del Golfo y otras
bandas de narcotraficantes un camino que
podría ser arduo para el gobierno Petro